another one is Jimmy Dore we had Jimmy
on we had a lot of fun with him I didn't
know a lot about Jimmy and then
everybody said hey Jimmy same way
they're saying about you I'm having a
lot of fun having you on how Jimmy I'm
an interesting guy what do you think
about Jimmy well you know Jimmy uh and I
I don't know that we were friends
necessarily but we were simpatico and
then in like uh 2016 uh he was saying uh
stuff on his show I think he was back on
tyt at that time he had another show
he was okay with Peter Thiel being a
Supreme Court Justice he was talking
about how Donald Trump was going to
resurrect the Democratic party and
Donald Trump will get elected and if he
gets elected we'll get Elizabeth Warren
in in 2020. I mean these were all things
that he had come up with and you know I
I sent them an email I said look you
want to come on my show we should talk
about this because I think a lot of that
stuff is crazy and he said no no no and
uh so I started you know I said go ahead
rip me a new and so I I played
the clip and then he must have been
listening to the show because I take
calls I take live calls unscreened calls
that's cool every day and uh he calls in
and we have a debate and the guy Jimmy
called in yeah Jimmy called in from his
car I guess and and the guy didn't know
anything about what he was talking about
he didn't know what a filibuster was he
made all these predictions he said I
said look dude you get Donald Trump in
there there's a chance you get three
Supreme Court Justices he says uh you
you that's like the the moon could fall
into Lake Michigan well it turns out the
Moon fell into Lake Michigan
and and we're going to feel the effects
I mean for people I don't know if it
necessarily bothers you guys but for for
for me the idea of like not just rolling
back abortion but the the Voting Rights
Act
um uh I mean government agencies that
have the ability to do stuff I mean it's
massive I mean it is a tidal wave I
don't think American public totally
realized that could have been the single
biggest thing a president has done to
help their party the last 60 years or it
is the worst thing for the opposing part
McConnell I think gets that credit
because McConnell was the one who would
not even have a nomination hearing they
controlled the Senate would not have a
nomination hearing he kept that in
that's that's McConnell that's McConnell
I think that is the most under uh
understood reason why Donald Trump in a
million years would I have guessed you
would have been a supporter of Mitch
McConnell that kind of credit so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you